[Music]
one of the interesting features of
ursula kayla green's third earth sea
novel the far the shore
is that we now have ged in the prime of
his powers as the ark mage presumably
having about as much wisdom as he's
going to have in his life some of it
learned from bitter experience and there
are passages where he is communicating
what we can call
an ethical teaching and a metaphysical
teaching as well
to this young man aaron a nobleman who
pledges himself to ged to go on this
quest to find out what's wrong now with
the world and what has upset the
equilibrium or balance and brought in
some considerable
evil and so get is going to say things
at a couple different points and because
he's this character placed where he is
he can now communicate what has either
been learned by him through experience
and you know reflection upon it or
other people had told him along the line
and generally like young people do he
didn't pay close enough attention to so
we're getting this teaching coming to us
not in a sort of treatise but you might
say through the cracks in off moments in
places where ged thinks that it's
important to communicate something to
this young man as it's going to turn out
there's there's some good reasons he's
not just talking to anybody whatsoever
he's talking to somebody who has a
destiny ahead of him
as it gets revealed a little bit later
on in the novel and so when they first
encounter each other this is very early
on in the book and aaron
is pledged himself and is going to go on
this
quest with with gad aaron
is a sort of you know
we could say bewilderment why why me i
don't really have anything to offer he
says i have no great gifts or
skills um what use will i be to you
and ged says
um would you rather that somebody else
went with me and you stayed behind and
and uh aaron says no but i fear fear
what tears sprang to the boy's eyes to
fail you
and then ged says sit down i'm going to
tell you something
i did not mistake you for a wizard or a
warrior any finished thing what you are
i do not know though i'm glad to know
you can sail a boat what you will be no
one knows but this much i do know you
are the son of morid and of syriad iron
was silent that's true my lord but the
archmage said nothing and he had to
finish his sentence i am not morad
i'm only myself
god says you take no pride in your
lineage
yes i take pride in it because it makes
me a prince it's a responsibility a
thing that must be lived up to
and so ged then says here's the teaching
that is what i meant to deny the past is
to deny the future
a man does not make his destiny he
accepts it or denies it if the rowan's
roots are shallow it bears no crown at
this iron looked up startled for his
true name lebanon meant the roman tree
but the archmage had not said his name
your roots are deep you have strength
and you must have room room to grow so i
offer you instead of a safe trip home to
enlid an unsafe voyage to an unknown end
you need not come the choice is yours
but i offer you
the choice and aaron says my lord i
choose to go with you so you know think
about this for a moment
it's
it's it's a really interesting teaching
everyone has a destiny
now when we say that we often think of
determinism oh i have a destiny i gotta
go this way that's my only choice god is
not saying that you have a destiny you
can accept it and follow it or you can
try to go against it you can try to
escape it you can try to undo it you can
try to dominate it and make it be
something else but none of those are
really going to work
and you'll wind up with a different sort
of fate not necessarily
destiny
so that's a good place to start
everything that we do
has some sort of connection and
consequences and he talks quite a bit
about acts and choices in here one of
the very interesting parts early on when
they are disguised as
wayfarers
ged says
i don't want to go among men again
tomorrow i've been pretending that i'm
free that nothing is wrong in the world
that i'm not archmage not even sorcerer
that i'm hawk of tamir without
responsibilities or privileges owing
nothing to
anyone
and you know aaron is a little bit
surprised that if you're the archmage
why would you not want to be the
archmage well it comes with these
vast you know world responsibilities and
just getting to pilot a ship around a
bit and you know hang out and stuff like
that is kind of nice for somebody who's
in in power and um ged goes on and he
says
very seldom do you come upon a space a
time like this between act and act
where you may stop and simply be
or wonder who after all you are much of
the time we're
making decisions making choices acting
and these actions are connected together
in a vast nexus as we're going to see
sometimes we get a pause
and we get to just be who we are it
could be
by ourselves in solitude it could be
in the elements in this case out on a
boat pitching in the water it could be
with somebody else or even something
else cuddling up with a cat or in ged's
younger days with his otak right
but there are times like that between
act and act but
acts are very important through acts
that the world is maintained you could
say he says try to choose carefully
aaron when great choices must be made
when i was young i had to choose between
the life of being
and the life of doing and i leapt at the
ladder like a trout to a fly
but
each act you do each act
notice no exceptions
binds you to itself and to its
consequences makes you act again and yet
again
so
each thing that you do
has consequences and those consequences
are not just the full product of the act
those consequences lead into
new situations in which you do have the
trail of the past behind you much later
in there he talks about how
he
made a mistake he says i know how much
evil one man one life can do i know it
all too well
i know it because i have done it i've
done the same evil in the same folly of
pride i opened the door between the
worlds just a crack just a little crack
just to show i was stronger than death
itself i was young and had not met death
like you
it took the strength of the archmage
nemerla took his mastery and his life to
shut the door you can see the mark that
night left on me on my face but him
it killed and so he's saying you know
this is
here's a prime example of course this is
coming later on
in the teaching
he also explains
that there's a metaphysical
um reality i was going to say concept
but our concept is just the mere map of
that reality that these these mages call
the balance or the equilibrium and we
learned about this before in a wizard of
earth see now we learn a little bit more
about it here
in in what is told to aaron
so aaron and gad are having this
conversation
about what's been happening and he says
can it be a kind of pestilence a plague
and god says pestilence is emotion the
great balance we'll come back to that in
a moment and he says
every act takes place within
this balance
every act has the potential to
upset things a little bit later when ged
has rescued him from the slave ship
and ged didn't impose any sort of
penalty or punishment
upon the slavers he says i i don't come
to punish what he does is he removes the
chains from all of the captives and he
leaves things in their own hands
so um
aaron says
uh here we go why didn't you free the
other slaves and and god says i did i
left none bound on that ship
but edgar's men had weapons if you'd
bound them i if i had bound them there
were but six the oarsmen were chained
slaves like you edgar and his men may be
dead by now or chained by the others to
be sold as slaves but i left them free
notice i left them free to fight or
bargain i am no slave taker
but you knew them to be evil men was i
to join them therefore notice what he
says next to let their acts rule my own
when we allow ourselves to be dragged
into this process of retaliation we
allow others acts to determine our acts
to rule our own ged in his wisdom brings
a different possibility
he says i will not make their choices
for them
nor will i let them make mine for me
and then ged says
do you see aaron how an act is not as
young men think like a rock that one
picks up and throws and it hits or
misses and that's the end of it this is
a mistaken
concept of acts
when that rock is lifted
the earth is lighter
and the hand that bears it heavier
already you have changed things in the
world
when it is thrown
the circuit of the circuits of the stars
respond and where it strikes or falls
the universe is changed now these are
small changes of course throwing a rock
but what if you throw a rock and it
hits a person in the head and kills them
now that's a very significant change
what if you throw a rock and it causes a
landslide what if you throw a rock and
it plunges into a pool and saves a fish
that is about to be devoured by another
there are all different possibilities
he goes on and he says
on every act notice he says every act
not just on
important acts
on every act the balance of the whole
depends the winds and seas the power of
water and earth and light all that these
do
and all that the beasts and green things
do is well done and rightly done all of
these act within the equilibrium
from the hurricane and the great whale
sounding to the fall of a dry leaf and
the nant's flight all they do is within
the balance of the whole but we
human beings
insofar as we have power over the world
and over one another we must learn to do
what the leaf and the whale on the wind
do of their own nature we must learn to
keep the balance having intelligence we
must not act in ignorance having choice
we must not act without responsibility
who am i though i have the power to do
it
to punish and reward playing with
men's destinies and then aaron says well
does that mean you just don't do
anything
is the balance to be kept by doing
nothing surely a man must act even not
knowing the consequences of his act if
anything is to be done at all and god
says never fear
it's much easier for men to act than to
refrain from acting we will continue to
do good
and to do evil
but we have to start taking greater
cognizance of the responsibility that
our actions have for disrupting the
balance every act is possible within
the scope of the balance but it can
set things off
and what's going to happen as we find
out of course is the actions of the
sorcerer cobb have drastically affected
it so human beings can live within the
equilibrium or they can disrupt it in
very significant ways
there's also a difference between
the shifts of the equilibrium so going
back to the question about pestilence
right
can it be a kind of pestilence a plague
that drifts from land to land blighting
the crops and flocks and men's spirits
and ged says a pestilence is a motion of
the great balance of the equilibrium
itself
this is different there's the stink of
evil in it
right so
what makes it evil this is a key
question here what distinguishes between
badness
a hurricane coming and wiping out your
place that is indeed badness
and genuine evil evil exists within the
world of earth sea and evil is
not just you know
being mean or something like that
there's there's a source to it there's
reasons for it so he says
we may suffer for it when the balance of
things writes itself but we don't lose
hope and forego art and forget the words
of the making nature is not unnatural
this is not a writing of the balance
what's going on but an upsetting of it
there's only one creature that can do
that
what's that creature
a man aaron said tentative we men
and then here's a question why but a
little bit after that
um aaron says
what about dragons aren't they evil
do they do do they not do great evil and
god says the dragons are avaracious
insatiable treacherous without pity
without remorse but are they evil who am
i to judge the acts of dragons they are
wiser than men are it is with them as
with dreams air and we men dream dreams
we work magic we do good we do evil the
dragons do not dream they are dreams
they do not work magic it is their
substance their being
they do not do
they
are they
can they be said to be good or evil
perhaps not
coming back to human beings
what produces evil what leads to
evil what can disrupt the equilibrium
so
there's a couple different things that
are that are said here um one is about
greed
he says
when we crave power over life endless
wealth unassailable safety immortality
then desire desire is okay
desire becomes greed
and if knowledge allies itself to that
greed then comes evil then the balance
of the world is swayed and ruin weighs
heavy in the scale
and you know he
aaron says i thought that
wizardry depends on the balance though
how can wizardry
be evil in any respect and gad goes on
and he says
every land of earths he knows of witches
who clashed unclean spells sorcerers who
use their art to earn to win riches but
there's more the fire lord who sought to
undo the darkness and stop the sun at
noon was a great mage even arith akba
could scarcely defeat him the enemy of
mordred was another such when he came
whole cities now to him armies fought
for him the spell he wove against morad
was so mighty even when he was slain it
could not be halted and the island of
salia was overwhelmed by the sea and all
on it perished
those were men in whom great strength
and knowledge served the will to evil
and fed upon it so there's a
will to evil and then there's a question
of what happens with this will what acts
what choices what
capacities
what consequences are involved
a bit later
when he's talking about about evil as
well he is going to
bring up another
you could say
[Music]
if we're talking about greed and life
and immortality the fear of death is
another one
so
he says
listen to me aaron you will die you will
not live forever
nor will any man or anything nothing is
immortal but only to us is it given to
know that we must die
that is a very great gift the gift of
selfhood
for we have only what we know we must
lose what we are willing to lose
that selfhood which is our torment and
our treasure and our humanity does not
endure
it changes it is gone a wave on the sea
would you have the sea grow still and
the tide ceased to save one wave to save
yourself would you give up the craft of
your hands and the passion of your heart
and the light of sunrise and sunset to
buy safety for yourself safety forever
that is what these people are doing
those who are following the
person who's offering them immortality
and he he goes on and he says
that is the message
that those who know how how to hear have
heard by denying life you may deny death
and live forever
and he says that message i do not hear
aaron for i will not hear it i will not
take the council of despair
you and your innocence and courage and
your unwisdom and loyalty are my guide
the child i would send before me into
the dark so aaron has to choose what he
himself is going to
do
with this right
and the the issue the question
is
how one is going to deal with this this
fear of death this desire for life
that is what leads to evil
taking the wrong
choice
over and over again when it comes to
that
the last thing that i want to
bring up here
is that returning to this issue of ged
saying i screwed up myself
aaron
asked aaron says well aren't you still a
good man
you know
ged says the door between light and
darkness can be opened to shut it again
that's a different story
and aaron says but my lord what you
speak of is true surely different than
this and god says why because i'm a good
man
what is a good man is a good man one who
would do no evil who would not open a
door into the darkness who has no door
who has no darkness in him look again
lad look a little farther you will need
what you learned to go where you must go
look into yourself
did you not hear a voice say come did
you not follow
and he says i thought that voice was his
the dark mage right and god says yes it
was his but it was also yours
how could he speak to you across the
seas but in your own voice how is it
that he calls to those who know how to
listen the mages and makers and seekers
who hear the voice within them how does
he does not call to me it is because i
will not listen
um i i'm not going to obey you could you
have to make a choice you have to act
you have to decide
for yourself and that
it's not that there's inherent goodness
within us that we just tap into and rely
upon and once it's damaged it's gone no
the goodness exists through acting
through aligning ourselves once again
in the difficult choices with this
equilibrium and refusing the temptations
that we could give into
get is saying to aaron
this evil guy who's undoing the
equilibrium itself and maybe destroying
earthsea
he's not that radically different from
you and i except in the choices that
he's making and in the powers that he
has harnessed same thing with the people
who are going along with him to their
ruin so this is some very
interesting well worked out ethical
reflections and councils on the part of
ged that we could see enfolded here
within the story itself if we're too
eager for the action itself of the story
we might miss this stuff but you know
upon
subsequent readings it becomes very
clear that this is what is motivating
ged and this is what he is teaching
aaron
you